hey Chase in the cup coverage incredible
last night inside the Fortress golden
knights clinched game two against the
Panthers what a game eight Sports now is
Ron Futrell joining us with a recap some
highlights big smiles and woohoo good
morning everybody good morning Heather
everybody stay up and watch the game
last night
five o'clock start so easier for us with
the morning stuff here okay game two
last night T-Mobile Knights get the job
done once again take a tune at the lead
in this series there's the suspense for
you okay start out with the waner blast
and the siren oh he just crank it hope
he's okay there want anything all right
Mark sure Nook says hey is okay okay
let's get it going here nice one opening
game 5-2 last night oh it's right off
the bat Jonathan marks yourself with the
goal he had two of them last night then
Alex Martinez with one of his own he's
got his name on the cup already twice
with the Kings he wants it on with the
Knights certainly now the hit of the
game Jack eichel Center Ice has the puck
Matthew kachuk takes him down and out
now remember Jack eichel had neck
surgery back in November 2021. he goes
off the ice
in pain a little bit of a scrum right
there concerned it was two minutes left
so that's why he went off the ice here
and it's four nothing at the time so
that's what this is Florida this is what
they do okay they're an angry team a
nasty team belligerent team put all
those adjectives you want on there that
was unnecessary that hit
certainly watch it in real time here and
see how quick and how fast they're both
going they're both skating about 40
miles an hour
but that hit on eichel is what
everybody's talking about today
I mean he gets a massive hit there goes
in the locker room first shift back in
the third period he gets on the floor
check on the body wins his battle finds
me I mean
that's the resiliency that we have in
that locker room hopefully that uh
you know they're thinking about that a
little bit as they're coming to Florida
I think that could work in our favor but
we definitely have to prepare
um you know give everything into this
one game here and just get a little bit
of momentum back I I just I was a little
bit surprised by it I I didn't I think
one of those misconducts I I deserve but
I don't know about the other one but at
the end of the day it's
um you know they might have thought that
game was a little bit Out Of Reach maybe
in the second period but we certainly
didn't
okay it was four nothing at the time
there's Chuck right there in game one
Nick hague's being held held by the
throat and he throws a left to the face
of hey he got a 10 minute misconduct
penalty for that he's had three ten
minute misconduct penalties so far in
this series it's only two games into it
so they go back to Florida for game
three five o'clock on Thursday they may
need some better padding
yes but the Nitro nights are going at it
with them okay they're not letting them
you know bully them and they're also
scoring 12 goals in two games nine
different goal scorers and that's what
really matters that's what really is at
the end of the day what's your name on
the cup you score more goals I love it
we're going to hoist it awesome Ron
thank you so much